meine tochter hat zwei papas und eine
mama popstar eheleute long bekannt von
der boyband court indirekt ist einer des
stolzen papa sein traum hat sich mit
seinem partner ibo und leihmutter ihr
erfüllt auch wenn er wie kein leichter
war jetzt zum ersten mal zeigt dabei
bild seine moderne regenbogenfamilie
inklusive sie sehen ist der süßen
tochter in die der das ist absolut
modernes familienglück und passend dazu
ist mir jetzt auch live zugeschaltet
hallo ihren guten und hey dass meine
kleine schönste die augen zu 100 minuten
sie hat gerade die augen zu er hoffe
dass die jungen fans
warum wer weiß schon dass ein land ein
kräftiges thema vor meinen alten museums
geblieben ich verstehe
du hast jetzt auch gleichen termin hast
du uns erzählt aber zeit für bild hast
du dir jetzt noch genommen erzählt uns
warum gehst du mit deiner
familiengeschichte jetzt so in die
öffentlichkeit
außerdem jünger ein kind habe ich
eigentlich immer in mango gehabt seien
gute beispiele ich glaube dass die beste
erziehung positive beispiele seien und
mit mit mit unseren familien können wir
eigentlich zeigen die die normale und
harmonisch es war uns zu hause ist außer
hatte gerade auch yuja wang kommt in die
am telefon und wir haben aber heute
gesprochen wie stolz wir sind vielleicht
wenn man beim menschen überzeugen können
dass die ihr leben es ist natürlich
besonders passiert nicht so oft aber ich
sage immer wie es bei uns ist ist
einfach ganz normal also die harmonie
ist da und ja wir lieben uns und in die
harmonie und seine mama die sie liebt
und zwei papas sogar also so besonders
sind die eigentlich nicht das klingt
wunderschön und wir finden dass auf
jeden fall super wie ist das für deine
kleine prinzessin zwei papas eine mama
ist das komisch für sie oder total
normal auch wieder da
die hat sie weiß nichts anderes das
coole da ist wenn wenn denn wenn ihnen
die freunde oder freundinnen zu hause
hat dann hören wir oft die geschichte
zurück von die eltern familie freunde
oder freundinnen dass die kinder dann
gefragt habe ja wäre es vielleicht für
uns auch möglich um ein zweiter papa zu
organisieren hause die kinder sehen
dadurch vorteilen und ja wie gesagt
deshalb hinaus wichtig um es einmal zu
wiederholen
das heißt regensburger familien das ist
vielleicht eine lehre zieht so aber auch
mein neues leben fertig los habe sogar
eine cd labels aus erschlagen und sozial
wichtig ist aber wir sind eigentlich
normal wie wie in roland kaiser oder
holzschuhe aus so und das ist eine
wichtige botschaft was ein kind wiegt
braucht es harmonie und das bringen wir
uns struktur um das bringen wir auch so
wie ich bin stolz auf unsere familie in
die legt die haube zeit nahm und die
haube zeit bei uns umsonst ist
eigentlich ganz alles großartig denn die
sollte ja eigentlich ein zwillingsbruder
haben der ist allerdings zu früh auf die
welt gekommen und verstorben
wie war diese zeit für dich ja das ist
wie die man zuhause sich vorstellen kann
man ein alptraum
um gleichzeitig eine geburt zu haben
aber auch ein kind was es nicht
geschafft hat es gab es sogar zwei tagen
unterschied zwischen zwischen milan und
zwischen indie das war ein auftragen und
das ist ja die hat damals ein trauma
etwas was wir noch immer natürlich tief
in die fraktion mittragen
ich habe seine nach auf meine art hatte
wählen lassen
weil weil ich finde es total wichtig
wenn wir über die häme kinder auch reden
oder über singen oder an sie denken da
sind sie nicht wirklich web admin
umgehört
gleich vier uhr zu uns und firmen
familien aus indie und ja aber auch ein
song gewidmet ob mein augenstern
familien weil wie gesagt man meinen
ich habe glück dass ich dass ich singen
kann und mit musik eine botschaft
verbreiten kann und er hat das verdient
jeden fall aber sag mal es ist nicht
wahnsinnig schwer für dich so ein titel
zu performen
es gilt wiederum sie die haut kleine das
ist ja ein gänsehautmoment und uns wenn
man auch sieht ich habe das lied schon
einmal live gesungen wäre meine zu aber
wenn man sieht wie es ankommt bei die
menschen und das leben mit musik das ist
zwar meine geschichte ist wenn ich als
sänger aber wenn denn wenn die menschen
es hören wenn sie sich dann
identifizieren können mit was das singen
das ist ja das ist so besonders ist dass
das singen da stand ja in den sterne ich
hoffe das lied begleitet mich noch viele
jahre und es bleibt etwas ganz besonders
dass deswegen darf
die läuft vielen dank wir wünschen dir
das auf jeden fall auch alles und wir
wünschen seiner ganzen familie
gesundheit viel glück und alles was man
sich ebenso wünschen kann danke
wir sind da steht sie als olympische
familie dass wir diesen diese art und
weise zeigen können wo heute die zeit zu
hause
großartig und wir sind super glücklich
darüber dass sie bei der sendung dabei
wird hallo alles gute